hey guys it's max in this video we are
going to be comparing the brand new
airpods max to apple's airpod pros
and helping you decide if it's worth
upgrading
or if you're trying to figure out which
one of these you should buy you know you
want a pair of apple airpods something
that's high-end has all the convenience
features
is it worth spending the extra money on
the maxes
is the sound quality that much better is
the active noise cancellation that much
better
what about the transparency modes what
about delay we're going to be taking a
look at all of that in this video
other than the 250 versus 550 dollar
price
the biggest difference is the
convenience i love that the airpod pros
are so small
i literally take them with me everywhere
they slip into my pocket
and they just disappear i don't notice
them and whenever i want them
i have them accessible so that is
awesome with the airpods max
obviously you guys see this massive size
we have this purse style
case that puts him into deep sleep mode
it's adjustable and just the weight and
size difference
is huge you're not going to be able to
take this everywhere you go
it's more like you're throwing it into a
backpack you're traveling things like
that
so if you only have to choose one or the
other
i would lean towards the airpod pros
just for the fact that you can take it
with you everywhere
now as far as build quality the airpod
pros are really nice they are completely
plastic
but they don't feel cheap at all they
feel really premium
they look good but they still don't
compare to the airpods max which are
made
mostly out of aluminum and stainless
steel we have some
really nice cloth here this little kind
of
net design and then the cups are cnc'd
out of full aluminum so as far as
the feel and how premium it is this
definitely feels
very premium whereas the air pods they
just feel good now as far as controls
both
are very good the airpods max have this
digital crown
and it's really convenient to be able to
just spin to adjust your volume
you can also press it multiple times to
do certain actions like skip songs
or go back and then we have this single
button if you want to toggle between
active noise cancellation off or
transparency mode as far as the airpod
pros you have these stems that are on
them and you actually just press
down and it senses in it makes a little
audible click so you can switch between
songs
you can toggle your active noise
cancellation in the different modes by
holding down
but the one thing you can't do is change
your audio with them you have to use
siri
and then ask siri to change it well you
could do the same thing with the airpods
max but you don't have to as far as
volume so you can quickly and easily
just be able to
scroll and adjust it another convenience
feature with the macs
is that you can actually use them wired
it doesn't come in the box but for 35
bucks
you can get this lightning to three and
a half mil adapter so if you have a
laptop
or a computer that doesn't have
bluetooth or not a good one
you can use it this way where of course
with the airpods pros
you can't do that now the airpods do
have one
very convenient thing you can use one of
these in your ear at a time so if you
don't want to hear
full audio you won't be able to hear
your kids really well
you can do that and then the other one
can charge you just swap between them
whereas with the max you don't have the
option but of course they both have
transparency mode
so we're going to be comparing that in a
second now as far as
battery life the airpod max is rated at
20 hours with active cancellation
whereas the pros they're rated over 24
hours
when you include the case if you're just
using the earbuds
then you're looking at about four to
five hours and you've got to pop them
back to charge
and when you go to charge you'll get
about one hour of listening
and five minutes of charging whereas the
max will actually give you an hour and a
half
in that five minutes and now we're gonna
do a latency test for those of you guys
that might wanna do video editing with
bluetooth headphones or
gaming i'm gonna start out with the
airpods pro
and i have call of duty mobile opened up
right here we previously did this test
and they got about 150 milliseconds
which for gaming
isn't too noticeable it's still a very
good experience even bluetooth
headphones compared to about
500 with a lot of other ones i'm gonna
go into the menu here because it's the
easiest way to test it and
let's go ahead and click
i wonder if these got better over time
or maybe that is 150 milliseconds very
little delay
basically as soon as i press it very
shortly after
okay that is really good let's go ahead
and set these
put these on no difference whatsoever a
very slight delay if i'm trying to focus
on it
but very minimal so
basically if you're going to be playing
or editing you do have a very small
delay that you could notice when you hit
the space bar when you're playing back
your timeline or when you shoot
but it is very minor and if you're not
trying to look for it you won't
notice it now with some other ones
somebody's trying to shoot you in call
of duty
you're going to hear them half a second
later with a lot of the samsung ones
even with their
low delay feature on the android phone
so overall
definitely good for bluetooth headphones
and now let's go ahead and compare
the microphone quality i'm going to
start out with the airpods
pro and i have my voice memo app here to
record my voice
we're going to do this both in this room
that has fairly loud ac vent
noise um so it's gonna have to try to
cancel that out and then we're gonna
step
outside where it's quieter this is the
microphone quality of the airpods pro
in a room that has a lot of hvac noise
this is the microphone quality of the
airpods max
in a room that has a lot of hvac noise
alright let me know down below what
differences you heard and which one
sounded better
and then let's just go ahead and step
out into a quiet environment
this is a microphone test with the
airpods pro in a fairly quiet
environment and this is the microphone
quality of the airpods max
in a fairly quiet room and now let's get
into what you guys have been waiting for
we're going to start comparing the sound
quality and the active noise
cancellation
i'm going to start with that and let's
go ahead and put in the airpod
pros these things sound fantastic
for earbuds and i actually recently took
a flight the first one in
pretty much a year and they did a pretty
good job but i did wish for
a little bit more i'm currently in
transparency mode so let's go ahead and
switch over to active noise cancellation
all right it's on and
almost all the noise went away from our
vent that's up there
we have this blower ac room right behind
us and the furnace is always
on no matter what in this office
building and
that hum we always have to denoise it
from our videos so putting these in
almost all of it is gone i still hear
some of the high frequency sounds though
of the air going through the vent
and pretty much all the headphones i've
tested
still have that so definitely a good
improvement
let's go ahead and take these out now
first thing i noticed is the ambient
mode but we'll talk about that in just a
sec let's toggle the noise cancellation
okay well there should be a big
difference because these have
nine microphones and huge drivers in
this over-the-ear seal
whereas the airpod pros have four mics
two which are on the external two are
internal ones just for eq but
i literally don't hear anything
at all my voice is cut down dramatically
and i mostly just hear my mild tinnitus
that i have
can't get rid of that but other than
that i hear nothing from the vent
at all i don't hear the furnace ac noise
whatsoever so definitely the noise
cancellation
is much much better let's go ahead and
compare
the transparency mode here you go all
right vadim go ahead and talk again all
right man how do you hear me now
awesome is it like keep talking is it
like real life it sounds like real life
right keep talking
it how is it different pretty much
pretty much the same nice let's put on
these bad boys and
let me switch them over here all right
go ahead and talk with him all right man
how do you hear me with the maxes
all right little better but yeah keep it
better a little better
better than the airpods both are
fantastic
these are slightly better i mean these
seal in your ears
so they seal in uh they sound
probably about 95 of what you would hear
without them
awesome they sound amazing now the maxes
they sound
99 of wisdom
crazy dude it is so insane how close it
is
vadim i want you to check this out come
over here
sit down i'm here let's do this this is
insane we should have done this in our
first video
oh whoa okay that's what you're
transparency right that's transparency
you hear just
just like i'm talking right yeah okay so
now whoa that's weird okay
cool now go the off mode all right
whoa that can't be off that can't be off
it sounds like a noise cancellation i
gotta hear my voice so loud in my head
now go to noise cancellation what the
heck
how do you like that whoa
feels like him in uh what's what's that
isolation chamber
joe rogan talked about i don't know it's
so weird yeah okay
toggle transparency mode how good is
that transparency mode
dude here hold on okay hold on all right
talk
how good is that transparency mode what
in the world you might be
i don't know if you're blocking any of
the mics or not but oh that's crazy i
can hear
it the fan everything it is insanely
good it doesn't sound digital oh it's
crazy
all right my turn again and now it's
time for
the biggest most important thing sound
quality how much better do the maxes
sound is it dramatic enough
to spend the extra money to deal with
the size let's go ahead and put
the airpod pros in that do sound quite
good
especially when you consider the size
and everything else that comes along
with them
let's go ahead and connect over here the
first track i'm going to listen to
is where we started we often use this
one so i'm very familiar with it and we
can play it for you guys as well since
it's no copyright
let's go ahead and start with the airpod
pros
vocals sound good not too bright very
smooth
that bass nice deep rich bass
i don't want really any more sounds good
and now we're going to switch over to
the max
okay it's very interesting
her voice sounds so similar
okay and then that bass kicks in it's
not overpowering
but has a lot more depth to it sounds a
lot more
rich sounds wider
[Music]
definitely a lot more separation between
all those little notes
[Music]
it's almost like some frequencies i hear
here some i hear
further away some closer the vocals are
like right in the center there the
biggest difference is with the airpod
pros
i feel the sound like in my head kind of
in one spot just
right here with the airpods max i don't
hear them
right where they're at everything feels
much wider almost like i have a
surround sound with a bunch of speakers
and then i can differentiate between the
different frequencies
much more so than with the airpod pros
but of course this is one track
on youtube so let's listen to something
else this song is kind of a modern
classic song with some piano some bass
notes let's go ahead and take a listen
i love the piano that's in there
[Music]
and kind of switches between sides
[Music]
nice base pretty tight not too deep i
feel like i'd want maybe a little bit
more depth
but still rich and a little
sounds really good pretty loud too
[Music]
that sounds good let me skip ahead a
little bit to the special spot here
that little note it's like stretching
for the other side there
that sound a little bit harsh on the
high notes
okay
that section where it got louder and the
frequencies got higher just sounded a
little bit
harsh and um i am listening pretty loud
i love listening to music loud i think
if i turned it down a little bit
it would sound a little bit better there
i think we're maxing out these
these headphones as far as what they
could do now let's put on
the maxes let's go
so far sounds pretty similar but we're
just getting into it
[Music]
some of those high notes it's
interesting it's almost like they're not
being pushed up
as high they sound a little smoother but
they're very well separated
from the other sounds
[Music]
the piano it's so
okay i don't want to pause this but i
hear from one ear
and not only does it switch directly to
the other ear i actually like feel the
key presses
moving across through my
[Music]
the ears it's not any heavier it's not
amplified anymore but it is richer
[Music]
okay here's this tone
sounds so sweet
yep
oh okay very interesting i'll tell you
in a second
nice
oh i like that part but i paused it very
interesting okay so
with the airpod pros this song is a
bigger difference than before
definitely a bigger difference with the
airpod pros i feel the audio switching
from the left
from the right to the left the piano but
with these oh my god like i mentioned
i feel like i can hear the person
playing moving down the
piano and the notes moving from one side
individually it's a lot more
clear a lot more clarity there and with
that when we're switching between some
of those notes
instead of just switching from left to
right it's also like it's going from
up here down digging low which is very
interesting we don't have multiple
drivers here that are simulating that
maybe it's just because they're bigger
drivers
but the whole musical experience there
is quite a bit better now they're
actually a little bit quieter than the
airpod pros
which i was not expecting and then when
we got to that end
um where we have that one note that's
being stretched out and it goes higher
and it sound a little bit harsh at the
high frequencies
and everything kind of blended together
the couple different notes that are
there
you still get perfect separation and
it's still
super clear it doesn't sound um
crispy or anything like that that was a
pretty big difference
next we're gonna do a base test but not
your typical bass test with a bunch of
boominess
medium shared with me this dark knight
live concert and in between two tracks
at the three minute mark
there is some very deep sub bass
frequencies that
you really won't even hear on a phone
there's one tiny frequency that you can
barely hear on the phone but almost
everything else there you don't hear at
all so let's go ahead and put in
the earpods the pros here
you guys can listen to this with your
headphones as well hit play
ooh vadim vadim
i hear i hear those low frequency notes
with a lot of earbuds you're not going
to be hearing those that sounds good
trying to replicate it for you guys oh
that little violin coming in
there you go now it's getting louder
louder
you get this is an awesome concert oh
yeah
all right that sounded good i'm
surprised good job apple on those i mean
i like how those sound
let's test out the max woo
gleam
it's like the heart shaking kind of the
thing that the base that moves you that
you don't hear you feel
so much richer right there where it
kicks it up a notch
we're at the 315 320 mark
okay that violin right there instead of
just hearing it in between my ears
i heard it kind of moving across
separating very nicely
the guitar right there okay i wanna i
wanna keep listening but i'm not gonna
keep listening to that
i was surprised i didn't think the
airpods would be able to hit that low
they do they're just not that loud and
definitely not that rich
it sounds phenomenal here i would wanna
watch the movie
with these headphones on this really has
me wondering how low can the airpods pro
go i wasn't expecting them to go as low
as that track did
my phone i couldn't hear anything at all
so i'm gonna go ahead and run
some different frequencies and then i
will get back to you and tell you guys
how they compare
as far as ultra low bass all right guys
that was interesting i listened to
some sweeps some separate different
frequencies and then some songs and
there's a pretty big difference now i
have to say i am impressed
with the airpod pros because they
actually are audible at 15 hertz as low
as that but very faint and 30 hertz is
kind of where it's still usable it's
fairly loud all the way down to 30 hertz
which is pretty impressive now the
airpods
max i actually first start hearing them
at 10 hertz
of course it's not loud and 25 hertz is
still
very usable and it's still very loud so
overall
these are good these are a lot better
now 30 hertz they're
a lot more rich as well you don't just
hear the bass you actually
feel it which is awesome now along with
that i also played this song which is
tuned down to 25 hertz
and it was a massive difference here
absolutely massive
now with the airpods pro i mostly heard
the vocals you guys can listen to
yourselves and there's only kind of one
bass note when it goes higher up i'm
guessing 30 hertz
where it still stood out and sounded
good but most of the other notes i
barely heard them the song didn't sound
great
putting on the max man
the vocals were no longer the main thing
in the song the bass was the main thing
in the song
it would dig so deep and it's loud
enough
down to 25 hertz maybe 20 hertz even
where it's enjoyable and that bass is so
rich
and the vocals are kind of a secondary
part to the bass
so the difference in ultra low frequency
bass is pretty massive
and the maxes will be absolutely awesome
for watching movies
and now let's listen to some rock music
rock is often very difficult there's a
lot of different instruments being
blended together we have vocals
a lot of it is very loud constantly so
we found this track here you guys can
listen along
with us and let's start out with the
airpod
pros good strong vocals there little
faint violin in the background
a lot of different sounds that sounded
good but it was
a little bit i don't want to say flat
but everything is very similar so i'm
very excited to hear
how the macs are going to sound all
right let's go
wow that voice much more distinctive a
lot more clear
stands out a lot the violin i hear
right here it's not it's a little bit
louder but it's a lot more
distinctive a lot more richness
in the drums there the bass guitar
oh i can like take each instrument and
focus on it
very easily little drums right here
[Music]
wow i don't know what that is if that's
a
synthesizer but
wow okay how do i describe it well it's
like you're buying a flat screen tv
and you're using the built-in speakers
and all the frequencies are blending
together
you can turn it up loud but it doesn't
mean it sounds good
and this is like getting a nice home
theater system where
the quality and the richness and the
separation of the instruments
stands out and you just get an awesome
experience
alright guys now it's time for the final
verdict
is there a big difference and is it
worth upgrading or choosing one or
having both really adding it on so as
far as edm
electronic with vocals that's actually
where i heard the least
difference the airpod pros sounded good
the max's sounded better
but maybe 20 better in certain parts a
little more rich in the bass
vocals are very similar not a huge
difference now going into something more
like
classical music with some bass that's
probably about a 50 percent difference
when you add in the sound stage with all
the little instruments that you can
listen to and hear add in the separation
you add in how clear the little piano is
and the strings
that's a pretty nice difference here
that's where it's starting to make it
worth
the extra size and weight and price now
when we take it a step further
and you go into rock music massive
difference
not only fifty percent difference at
least a hundred or maybe even two
hundred percent you go from a sound
where all the different instruments and
sounds that are all loud at the same
level they're all blended together it's
hard to separate it
sounds all right there in the middle the
vocals are kind of muffled to an
experience that is
much better in every single way if you
listen to a lot of rock music listen to
metal
absolutely you have to go for the max
it's worth
all the extra size and price massive
difference and along with that
i also want to add in some true
classical i was listening to some
beethoven a lot of those
classical songs they started very quiet
different layers of instruments start
coming in
and because the active noise
cancellation is so good on the max
you're able to distinguish and enjoy
that without any other background sounds
as the song is building it is an awesome
experience for people that love
listening to classical music so
overall i might surprise you guys if
you're just buying
one pair of headphones unless you listen
to a lot of rock
i would go for the airpod pros they're
cheaper very convenient the sound
quality is really good unless you're an
audio file
but if you're somebody listens to rock
or you don't care about the size or
logical environments absolutely go for
the max or at least
add them to your collection especially
if you're somebody that goes
on trains subways or if you're stuck at
home right now and you don't need the
portability of the airpod
pros so there you guys go that is my
opinion we are gonna have a review on
this so click that circle above to
subscribe we're gonna do some very
interesting tests for you guys
you won't want to miss it and click the
one of those videos over there there's
some awesome videos that you guys can
check out we have links in the
description
this is relax and i'll see you in the
next video